اجرت الصين تغييرات كبيره في سياستها
لاحتواء كورونا شامله الغاء الحجر الصحي
للوافدين اليها
في مركز السيطره على الامراض في الصين ان
السلطات ستنشر المعلومات عن الاصابات
الجديده مره واحده في الشهر وذلك بعد خفض
تصديف
المرضيه الصينيه الى اجراءات الوقايه من
وباء كرونه يجب ان تكون علميه ومعتزله ولا
ينبغي ان تؤثر على المبادلات العاديه
للافراد واضاف المسؤول
الصينيا على تعديل سياسه التاشيره للاجانب
قال رئيس الوزراء الياباني
ان بلاده ستشدد ضوابطها الحدوديه على
المسافرين القادمين من الصين التي تشهد
زياده في اصابات 19 وذلك اعتبارا من 30 من
الشهر الجاري
جميع المسافرين القادمين من الصين وكذلك
اولئك الذين ذهبوا الى البر الرئيسيه
الصين في غضن سبعه ايام عنده وصولهم الى
اليابان
تثبت اصابتهم بفيروس سيطلب منهم من الحجر
الصحي في منشات المخصصه لمده سبعه ايام
في عدد الرحلات الجويه من الصين لمزيد من
الحمايه الصحيه حسب وصفه